pour moi les enfants encore mais avec
une note d'espoir hier à nantes sous
l'égide des médecins du monde et de la
municipalité de nantes
un bateau a pris la mer à son bord 14
enfants venus du monde entier pour
réaliser une croisière qui va les mener
à new york en empruntant le chemin des
anciens navires transportant des
esclaves vers l'amérique
l'idée de cette croisière symbolique et
bien soutenir la signature par les
nations unies d'une convention pour le
respect des droits de l'enfant reportage
de monique atlan et physiquement touazi
hier à nantes 14 enfants étaient à
l'honneur
quatorze enfants âgés de 12 à 16 ans
représentent dans une salle continent
désigné par les comités d'action écoles
et l'association enfance et partage pour
être par ce voyage symbole sur le
vendredi 13 les témoins et messagers de
tous les enfants qui souffrent dans le
monde
et si pour cette cause ils ont obtenu le
soutien des adultes concernés
ils ont choisi cette voie d'être
eux-mêmes ambassadeurs de leur propre
cause
les ambassadeurs conscient de l'enjeu de
leur mission chaque année 15 millions
d'enfants meurent avant l'âge de 15 ans
se tue en fin ou ceux qui sont
maltraités
pour les enfants qui se prostituent à
vers 10 12 ans je fais ça pour essayer
de pour trouver un endroit qui puisse
les aider
on part tous pour faire quelque chose
pour que ça set je viens de libranda
pays où il ya de la guerre et je vais
porter un message au monde pour qu'on
cesse la bière attire
leur mission remettre officiellement au
secrétaire général de l'onu
ghazi perez de cuellar ce qu'ils ont
tapé la parole des enfants afin de
soutenir la signature de la convention
des droits de l'enfant par au moins 21
le choix des étapes de la croisière se
veut lui aussi un symbole c'est que
faisaient les esclaves avant partenaires
poil et en anglais puis en martinique 1
go et j'ai changé les esclaves contre
les objets n'a aucune importance
faire de cette route la route de la
solidarité entre tous les enfants du
monde est à l'heure du départ le défi
qui trottent dans leur tête et qu'ils
ont choisi de relever face à
l'indifférence